post-pandemic do you think that science
has taken a battering when that people
have lost a little bit of faith in
scientists as a result of you know
things that people said for instance you
know that people were saying well you
know if you take the vaccine it means
that you can't pass it on the virus and
then that turned out not to be true now
obviously I'm not asking you to comment
on that but just do you think that
people are now just a little bit more
skeptical as scientists a little bit
more untrusting
so there are a couple of loose edges
there so let me let me uh explore that
with you all right so first
um
no single scientist
ever communicates the truth unless they
are communicating a consensus of
observations that have been made and
unfortunately I don't have a better word
than consensus to use in that sentence
because typically when we hear the word
consensus it relates to a a shared
opinion about something
in science it's not about opinions it's
about the results of experiments
and if you have a set of experiments
most of which lean in this direction
instead of that direction is like Hey
we're on to something here
and I'm gonna go with the consensus of
those observations and experiments and
they have nothing to do with the
individual
okay so what's Curious to me is we live
in an era where you can Channel surf on
YouTube is that what it's called Just
Surf on YouTube they're not channels I
guess you surf on YouTube and you land
on somebody who says the mainstream
thinks this is true The Establishment
thinks this but here's the actual truth
you're all in on that
okay no but why are you all in on that
uh and there's something about
the lone genius that we wanna we wanna
snuggle up to them rather than the
faceless establishment
because that person is speaking
passionately
and our response to fellow human
speaking passionately is well known in
the advertising industry
they could just show
you why their product is better than
everybody else's but no they have a
person saying I use this and it changed
my life and it'll change your life too
that's what you listen to
you we're blind to the statistical
representation of reality
and I'm okay we're human and do I
complain about that or just try to
navigate that I don't know
I do know we're not very good at
thinking statistically about the world
okay and if we were better at it no one
would play the lottery okay just let's
understand that all right and we have
people who exploit this ignorance
exquisitely and they're called Casino
owners okay they're exploiting the fact
that humans fundamentally do not
understand probability and statistics
okay so that's a that's an education
problem and that that Gap manifests in
adulthood with our susceptibility to
others who do know the statistics who
then exploit your ignorance of it
that's my first point another loose Edge
is we have institutions
and people representing institutions
where science research is conducted okay
or conducted under their auspices the
National Academy of Sciences the in the
United States the National Institutes of
Health and the UK surely has
corresponding agencies to this here's a
problem
how well do they know how to communicate
okay
we're not as scientists we don't take
graduate courses in communication and
how people will misthink what you say or
or how they will how you'll try to say
something in a way that no no no none of
them are trained in this so now we have
people in a once in a century pandemic
trying to communicate science to the
public okay
I don't want to call it a total disaster
but there were parts that it was like no
no
so with the benefit of hindsight
let me say
how it should have happened
okay
the CDC the Center for Disease Control
and prevention in the United States
here's what they should have said they
should have said here's what we know
today
based on a set of
research results that have come in okay
and you don't focus on one researcher
there's a The Ensemble okay here's what
we know and based on this
we recommend that
okay based on this we recommend that
we will update you weekly
on what we have learned because this is
a hot area of research
and as research comes in if it continues
to reinforce these results we will
continue to urge you you do these things
if we find research that does not
completely agree with that it might have
we will tell you that and we will be
honest about these uncertainties
okay and we will only make a a a a
federal level requirement
when we have the statistical confidence
in the research that has been conducted
that's how it should have unfolded but
it didn't that sounds so good Neil but
we were so so far away from that weren't
we
foreign